we've previously talked about the
reversing of the yield curve where you
will have a longer term bond that yields
a lower interest rate than a shorter
term bond and as I explained to you
before hopefully somewhat clearly I
always I'm never sure if I'm actually
explaining these things clearly enough
typically if you have the option of
locking up money for three years versus
five years you would expect to earn more
interest when you lock your money up for
five years because you are giving up
access to the money for a longer period
of time in exchange you would expect to
earn more of an interest rate and when
the yield curve reverses what it means
is that the longer bond actually yields
a lower rate and it's a known sign of
uncertainty and a negative outlook for
the longer future of the economy if
you're looking if you think the economy
is going to be a disaster over a
five-year term
you may be willing to accept a lower
yield to tie up the money for five years
because you expect that during that
five-year period it may get even worse
and you want to avoid a potentially even
lower return that's the sort of idea of
a yield curve reversal we now have a
different story which is that yesterday
briefly and the numbers keep fluctuating
the one in three-month Treasury bills
had yields go negative
okay so understand what this means with
Treasury bills and bonds prices and
yields move in opposite directions so if
you've got never talking nominally
imagine $100 par value bill with the 2%
nominal interest rate if I buy that bill
for a hundred bucks and I get two
dollars for each year that I hold it my
return is 2% and then when I'm done I
get my hundred dollars back for as long
as I've held it I've made 2% great
imagine that the demand for that hundred
dollar bond goes up people want to buy
that hundred dollar bond so even though
it's a hundred dollar bond or bill you
might pay a hundred and ten dollars for
it meaning you pay 110 you still get
your two percent off of the hundred
meaning your two bucks a year and then
when you give the bond back you only get
a hundred dollars back remember you pay
110 you get a hundred back because
that's the value the face value of the
bill and you got your two bucks your
interest rate your your yield has now
gone down and you have to of course
account for the ten dollars that you
lost but then you made two bucks a year
you can also add inflation in there and
you find out your real return when
someone says imagine that the demand
went up like crazy and you bought a
hundred dollar bond for 200 bucks it
still pays two percent of the hundred
dollars you're getting your two dollars
a year but when you sell that bond when
you give that bond back and you get the
money back out of it it's a hundred
dollar bond that two percent may not
have actually made up enough you may be
losing money in the net it would be an
effective negative yield on that bond
now that's the concept of how yields can
be negative or positive now what we're
talking about now is something a little
bit different yesterday the one month t
bill had a yield of negative 0.01
percent and the three month had a yield
of negative 0.03 percent so how is that
possible the math is that the yields can
become negative if the sale price of the
bond goes super-high meaning people are
desperate desperate desperate to buy
bonds even accounting for the interest
rate you could be looking at losing
money on that bond you will lose money
on the bond and what happened is that
the Fed slashed rates to zero so you're
starting with a zero interest rate and
there is such demand for a safe haven
for money that people are willing to pay
to have their money held in Treasuries
instead of earning 1% for letting the
government hold your money which is
normally normally the way it works is
you give the government money you earn
something for doing that when times are
so uncertain you might be willing to pay
the government point o 1% to hold the
money why on earth would you do this if
you believe the outlook is so grim
knowing you won't lose more than 0.01%
could be better when you're talking
about large amounts of money that could
be better than being exposed to larger
losses if you didn't do this
one other thing you won't necessarily
actually lose money with negative yields
on paper it's important to understand
that you could have deflation reach a
point where the cash payments from the
bond are actually worth the purchase
once you account for inflation this
stuff doesn't really matter the takeaway
is the most important thing is that this
is a signal about the insane level of
uncertainty that there is for the
foreseeable future I think most of you
probably understand that that that's the
most important bottom line and what this
is connected to of course are
coronavirus cases accelerating
unemployment the future of so many
businesses in the United States and
that's where I want to go next